all right i have a story today from my
birth country
of argentina and it is unfortunately
just like the worst of the worst of the
stereotypes about argentinians
one of the stereotypes about
argentinians
um is that uh they we
love to set ourselves apart from the
rest of latin america and say
the rest of latin america you know these
are hispanic people
but we're actually european now it's an
exaggeration
it's a stereotype it's extraordinarily
xenophobic and
and racist quite frankly and the current
argentinian president alberto fernandez
did exactly this during a meeting
with the uh spanish prime minister
alberto fernandez tried to sort of find
common ground and to connect with the
spanish prime minister
by highlighting hey we're european like
you guys and
in so doing he said you know the
mexicans are just indians
the brazilians came out of the jungle
we came on boats from europe we're
different and it is just the worst of
the worst now
many if you've been watching this show
for a while you know that i am not a
fernandez guy fernandez is in the line
of
christina kirschner and her late husband
i'm not i'm not a kirschner guy
now i'm also not a mockery guy i think
that basically in argentina
for decades now the choices have been
different types of corruption different
degrees of corruption none of which
serves the people
this is controversial among even within
my family where there are people who
uh are are big christina people who now
is the vice president they just love
christina
and they're gonna write to me because
i'm saying this and say i'm wrong about
this i'm wrong about that
it's one of the most disgusting regimes
that that i've seen
but i'm not a mockery guy he did some
good municipal projects but it's not
like i'm cheering about
center-right sort of trump trump-style
mockery so
in any case uh let's get into the video
i'm going to
um sort of translate i guess i would say
as we go there are some english
auto-generated subtitles but i will do
my best to kind of uh
let you know what's being said check
this out
[Music]
[Music]
so here he's basically saying listen
argentina is part of latin america
we are pro-latin america we are latin
american but me in particular
i'm also a europeanist is the word that
not a pianist a europeanist
um because i want we we consider
ourselves part of europe let's continue
i believe in europe
so now he's quoting octavio pass but he
clearly likes it and
here's where it gets bad que los
[Music]
mexicanos
[Music]
this this if if if you were to do a
parody and say
what stereotype about argentinians could
we exaggerate
to make argentinians look as bad as
possible
this would be the script which would be
you know they say the mexicans
came from indians nate natives and
native americans indiana
you know however whatever whatever
phrase is appropriate now to refer to
the native peoples
brazilians came out of the jungle as if
you can
imagine a more sort of primitive uh
imagery
um but you know we argentinians we came
from boats that came from europe
uh which of course is coded with racial
language
and it's it's just absolutely nuts let's
listen to just the end of it
europe is
[Music]
this is just the worst the worst the
worst of just
sucking up to the idea of of we
listen we develop we came from europe
and we developed the the country
with european investment and it's just
so
racialized and so xenophobic and so
disgusting
and in a sense it's not uh
um it it's it's not even an attack
it's it's just this off-handed uh
signal as to how he views
brazilians and mexicans in comparison to
argentinians i'm so humiliated by this
that this is so
embarrassing because among friends who
understand the stereotypes about
argentina sometimes there are jokes made
about stuff like this
and you know if you go to argentina and
you see there's essentially no
what we would consider black folks in
argentina there's a reason why it's
disgusting it's horrible the history of
it
um and uh you know there's a lot of
historical stuff here that
it would be great not to associate with
and then he just sort of like says what
for many of them is supposed to be the
quiet part
completely out loud i mean just just
absolutely humiliating and disgusting
this guy's horrible it's it's horrible
and
by the way if you want to if you want to
see corruption on a scale that would
make
it would even make trump blush okay look
at what's been going on with vaccination
in argentina just just look it up and
see what you think